you've been hanging around the
JavaScript community for any length of
time at all you've probably heard about
functional programming and the
functional stylish JavaScript and it is
the only way that you should be writing
your Java
the problem with that is I'm the guy who
has an oo P for design patterns in
JavaScript course and I'm reluctant to
board the functional programming train
for a lot of reasons better I might talk
to somebody I get this statement in
JavaScript functions are first class
objects have you heard this before yes
you know what my response to this is
functions are first class objects it's
right there in the phrase right so so
there's a lot of benefits here but and
we're not pure oo I know you can throw
tomatoes at me later but prototypal
inheritance all that stuff but I like
the object-oriented stuff and and so I
kind of had to get on board with this
idea so the first thing I want to do
just real quick is let's set the
groundwork for what is functional
programming and the best source always
to find definitions for anything is
Wikipedia
okay so wikipedia says this in computer
science functional programming is a
programming paradigm we're all on the
same page ok a style of building the
structured elements of computer programs
totally still cool right up until we get
to this the trees computations as the
evaluation of mathematical functions so
I I was a math major in college and in
my freshman year I took Cal 3 and then I
switched over to computer science cuz I
don't like math I it's just right there
I'm not happy but it ends with this
statement and if you've been doing
JavaScript for any length of time
and avoids changing state and mutable
data in JavaScript like we can't even
keep our types the same let alone the
data involved in the variables so it
just it doesn't work to me so
so this is why the the talk is called
functional style so functional
programming in JavaScript is not a thing
right functional programming in Erlang
or you know high school yeah that's fine
function programming javascript doesn't
exist but we can apply a functional
style that might help us get a little
better what's interesting is every time
I talk to people about this oh wait hold
on so Martin who created Scala says this
the programmers in that segment like
functional programming because it makes
code clearer better structured and
prevents many class of classes of errors
the interesting thing about this last
phrase prevents many classes of errors
is because functional programming
languages have what is called a compiler
that if you're doing things you
shouldn't be able to do it actually says
stop it's JavaScript does not do that if
you change something that's immutable in
JavaScript it just changes it okay it
just works so every time I talk to a
functional programmer or a functional
style JavaScript programmer I get this
phrase and you even heard it in the
introduction right pure functions are
awesome my question is always back why
and and I was having lunch with a guy in
in Kansas City and his phrase was
because they're pure I how can you argue
with that but pure functions are
beautiful why when you can get a
function to be pure it's like this
magical thing okay
side effects are evil how many of you
want to interact in IO in any way right
you obviously do so that's a side effect
right I would contend the interacting
with the IO is not an evil thing and I'm
not alone the problem it a lot of people
they talk about how awesome functional
programming is but they can't articulate
why but I had a conversation not too
long ago with this guy so if you're
going to tweet at any point tweet at may
Taylor and say hey I'm a Taylor thanks
for straightening John
I haven't he's a he's a lecture guy and
we were talking about functional
programming and and he's like yeah
you're thinking about this too hard
which I found very interesting because
the bit flipped for me in a very
interesting way when I started thinking
about this so think about this for just
a second you cannot a fool avoid side
effects period you can't because you
have to interact with IO right you've
got to do some things not all functions
are pure because if you can't avoid side
effects not all your functions can't be
pure and not everything has to be
immutable
however functional style this was this
is what he said that that changed
fundamentally my understanding of this
function style is about using less brain
power and making things simple is that
your understanding of functional style
programming like coming into this talk
you have to think less and things are
easier like that is not that doesn't go
with what we've been told right but I am
telling you as the guy who hates
functional programming because I'm an
Opie guy this clicked for me I'm going
to give you some examples of why but but
here's the thought functional style is
about small composable things that fit
together a lot of times it's goodbye a
style of building the structure and
elements of a computer programming more
importantly the style of building the
elements we're going to talk about how
we build elements in a functional style
that fit in the overall big picture as
ob developer I think of system right
you've got system thinking you're trying
to think of the whole big thing and then
you think about what your objects are
you think about how your objects
interact you think about all of these
different things are you thinking about
the big picture what sometimes we forget
about and we don't stop and think about
very clearly is the little picture the
two lines of code here and there that
potentially could cause us problems or
make us think harder than we need to
think and the reality is you've got to
think about both
so what I'm gonna do is we're gonna walk
through some code right we'll just walk
through some code and I'll kind of give
you some examples of how this works and
then we can talk about it a race how
many of you use a race in your
programming if if there's not a lot of
you than you're lying okay how many of
you are morally opposed to hand-raising
so I got more here usually I get one
Cori I had four so you don't have to
raise your hand for the whole rest of
the talk but the rest of you I expect
feedback okay so you use a race so if
you want to do something with an array
not just in JavaScript but across the
board we use this thing called the for
loop how many of you have ever written a
for loop yes okay so I'm just making
sure we're all on the same page right so
how many of how many of you have seen
code that looks like this so I've got a
list of numbers and I put a comment in
there so my next question will be easy
like what's gonna print out in my
console log just yes you're not gonna be
wrong I promise but you're thinking
about this pretty hard what's it gonna
be two through six two three four five
six and how do you know this how do you
know this to be true right so I'm
looping over the array for each item in
the list I'm adding 1 to it and you
could just read the comment if you
really want to and then console dot log
list and I have this the interesting
thing about this or this is a very
simplified example of things that become
very complicated very quickly but so the
the idea here that was you've got two
things you're trying to pay attention to
right here the two things you're trying
to pay attention to right here are this
the iteration code I've got code that
governs the iteration over my array and
then I have code that governs what I'm
doing with my array so I've got these
two things that are very tightly coupled
I've got it a race
got what we could what if we could start
to pull this stuff apart so that I don't
have to pay attention to multiple things
at one time and that's ultimately where
we want to get to with functional
programming functional style programming
is I don't want to think about more than
one thing at any given time I'd only
think about one thing
that's pure it's self-contained to
nothing else and that's it okay so
here's what we're gonna do in JavaScript
we have these cool little functional
style helpers for Java for a race so
list out Mac what is map dude
right what does map do it ultimately it
iterates over in a row and then applies
a function to it isn't that ultimately
kind of what this was doing right I'm
iterating over an array so what if I
told you you never had to write a for
loop again yeah that's kind of where
we're getting right you'd stop it write
list stop map will iterate and there's a
bunch of these there's let's not find
and let's stop reduce and we'll talk
about reduce here in just a minute
there's all of these cool little helper
things and then you just pass into it a
function so this is now our iteration
code this looks a little bit better than
what we had before so what were we doing
with each item we're adding one
generally you're doing more than that
right but I don't want to have to
explain a whole lot of code to get you
the idea so bear with me yes this is
simplistic but we're adding one item to
a list what we're going to do with map
is we're now going to introduce this
concept of a pure function I don't care
if anything else in your code is a pure
function this will be pure now what is a
pure function real quick and computer
science a function may be considered a
pure function if both the following
statements of the function hold true two
things very important here one it always
evaluates to the same result given the
same arguments period no exceptions if
you call this function with one and two
you get the same result every time Phung
and a bee that's a pure function math
dot random pure function no why because
it returns something different every
time that's the whole purpose of math
dot random don't go functional style on
random because that doesn't work it's
not what you want um the other thing for
a pure function is this evaluation of
the result does not cause any
semantically observable side-effect or
output such as output to i/o devices not
everything's gonna be pure not
everything has to be pure but in this
case when you're mapping when you're
doing a map over an array no
side-effects don't start writing to i/o
every time you map for a lot of
different reasons but the most important
one for this talk is because it's one
more thing you've got to pay attention
to and we don't want to have to pay
attention to so let's sum equal zero
function add a sum not a pure function
this this requires more brain power to
figure out what's going on because not
everything's right there stuffs up above
Brian we don't we don't want stuff up
above all right so why pure less things
to keep track of less brain power but
most importantly it's not a rule you
don't have to have it be pure but it's a
good idea okay so here's what you end up
with I have a pure function item return
item plus one does that appear function
yes
is it clear what's going on yes however
this is 2017 it's not like ten years ago
we don't use the function keyword
anymore now we do this right arrow
functions over who uses arrow functions
do you know why you use arrow functions
ah okay that's fine I'm not gonna
explain it because I don't have time but
and then if you do this and Cori does
your code review he says that's too many
characters I want this because I don't
need the parentheses and if it's only
one line I don't need the return so
right now this becomes much easier to
read there you go
I've replaced that big huge for-loop
with just this little thing still maybe
unclear
I do not like anonymous functions
anonymous functions especially in an FP
style make things a little less clear so
I created an add one function up above
list up map add one it's very clear
what's going on right
can you guess is it easier for everybody
to guess what list is gonna print out ah
I'm getting there
you ruined it but yes okay this this
prints out that Y ah that's this avoid
changing state and mutating data we
don't in the functional style we don't
mutate data Y so ok you some of you feel
very confident so I'm gonna like ask you
why don't we mutate data is it just one
of those FP things like you know tail
call recursions nobody wants to venture
a gas multi-threading in java scripts
this is where we're we're in Nebraska
yes man just totally fair okay but here
so here's why here's a couple of reasons
I'm not going to go through them a lot
but I just
so enforces options this one I'm going
to talk about easier to validate so
react state is immutable you should
treat state it was immutable that's a
very important distinction because it's
not actually immutable but and the
reason for that is if you change an
object's object a equals equals object B
now becomes false if you add something
to an object
you're both inside of an object that
still evaluates to true so you don't
know whether this thing is changed
without doing a deep compare most
importantly less brain power for that
reason and because you don't have to
worry about what's going on with all of
my stuff so here's what that looks like
I have options here look I can just say
list equals lists top map not that big a
deal I'm adding like a couple of
characters but if I don't want to change
it i don't i just assign it to something
else i have options available to me and
how I'm gonna handle my a rep so that's
very cool okay but what if we want to do
multiple things at one time how many of
you only do one thing in your for loop
like now we do a lot of different things
in our for loop all the time so let's
add one and then sum them so look add
one and then I'm gonna reduce my list so
reduce what reduce does is it basically
lets you aggregate down and a rag just
over an array and basically does a sum
or it can do an ADD or it could do a
group buy or to do whatever you want to
do but Val let's top map add one then
reduce it to some I get 20 by returning
the array instead of changing the array
I can just chain this stuff out and
actually written code recently that I
had like four or five of these things
and you just put the dot on the next
line it's very readable it's very easy
to see what's going on
this right here is why I've started to
really like the functional style because
this is a lot cleaner once you kind of
rock the idea this is a lot cleaner than
the big four loops the big monolith the
code that sits everywhere then you get
to this thing because it's easy when
you're talking about arrays and map and
pure functions and all these things but
then functional programming gets into
into weird stuff like currying how many
of you have heard this phrase before
all right here's what currying does
currying I have this function let's sum
equal a plus B or a comma B I'm passing
a and B in it's gonna pass me back to
some currying in mathematics again it
basically takes in a ret or a function
that takes multiple parameters and
breaks them up so you can pass one
parameter into each function so this
becomes this right I don't know why you
would ever do that that's weird but
here's that here's an example here's
here's one of the reasons I use currying
even recently at work in code so I have
a list of buttons this is easier to
explain mine was a list of dropdowns and
you had drop-down so I've got a list of
buttons that have a name and they have a
message so ceated with a button so it
should be easy - okay on click I have
this done click and I want to display
the message associated with the name how
would I do this so when you click the
button I'm gonna fire an on click event
I want to know I want to display the
message associated well in your on click
event I've got a loop back over my
buttons to figure out which button got
clicked or I could add something to the
Dom element or there's a bunch of
different ways to do it they're all
fairly more brain intensive what I
really want to do is this
I want to pass the index of my Dom
element my button into the on call that
I don't have to loop I just have my
index is right there but what is the on
click event handler past me can I change
the ant handler no it's gonna pass me
event no matter what I do but I think we
just talked about something that might
fix my problem right I want that so what
you end up doing is hey I have a get on
click event and my get on click event is
gonna pass me back a function that has
access to index now I don't have time to
explain this closures all right I got
one who knows what a closure is who can
articulate it nicely
okay that's all right no okay so here's
here's in it's in a nutshell here's what
a closure is when this function return'
function event message equals buttons
sub-index when that function is created
JavaScript's takes everything that's in
scope for that object and packages it
all and hands it off
so you're I'm not returning just the
function I'm returning the function and
the scope of that function that's a
closure so what's in scope for that
function index so index comes back
that's part of it okay so that's that
probably didn't help you at all but
that's my explanation of what closures
are so now I got on click event I'm
creating a new function you can get into
performance conversations I don't care
this is easier so this is what I'm doing
creating a new function now every time I
the button I get exactly what I want all
right so here's what I want to leave you
with because I'm right at time I want to
leave you with this idea that don't when
you start writing functional style don't
take a react app and say I need to
convert this entire application to the
functional style I need to kill
everything that I have and now
everything has to be immutable
everything has to be pure functions
because it's it's not possible you keep
my web application in JavaScript that's
purely functional what you can do is
start taking these little building
blocks of your code and start applying
this this functional style and I've
given you just enough to make you
potentially interested you can go look
at it there's a to clean up little
pieces don't clean up the whole code
base clean up this for loop right here
or clean up this one other thing right
here to make it a little cleaner a
little nicer and easier okay so that's
me thank you guys very much and if
you've got questions or something we can
chat how much
[Applause]